[Music]
it's time for et's late-night roundup
your quick catch up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark Jimmy Kimmel
sidekick Guillermo can now proudly call
himself a movie star he landed a small
role in the upcoming guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 and even got some coaching
from Chris Pratt and Kurt Russell
there's three looks the first one happy
scared that's all you need whatever you
do don't later in the show Charlize
Theron was a guest she opened up about
the Easter party she threw for her kids
last year featuring a disappointing and
dirty bunny like the nice fluffy white
but I don't know it was not just dirt it
was like is that food or is that vomit
and just lounging in my furniture really
yeah and I'm like this psycho mom going
get up over on watch would happen glide
with Andy Cohen the Americans co-stars
in real life couple Keri Russell and
Matthew Reese got candid about their
love story revealing they actually met
many years before filming their FX
series I very drunk in the ass of her
her number when she was a young single
slip of a thing so I sort of knew then
when I was 26 I want to say work where
it was there's a parking lot
very romantic
you
[Music]